Assalamu alaykum. Walaykum salam. I am
Hafi from Pakistan.
Why Allah has revealed four Islamic
books or revelations.
Why did he not complete his religion in
one book as he knows the knowledge of
future? He could have revealed only one
book which could be useful for all the
periods of times.
like till only Quran will be implemented
upon so that there were no divisions in
religion
for let me correct you brother Haf is
that Allah has not revealed only four
books Allah says in the Quran in surah
chapter number 13 verse number 38 Allah
says
in every age have we sent a revelation
but by name only four are mentioned in
the Quran the Torah the zabur the and
the Quran Torah is the revelation
which was given to Moses peace be upon
him. Zab is the revelation given to
David peace be upon him. Is the
revelation which was given to Jesus
peace be upon him. And Quran is the last
and final revelation which was given to
the last and final messenger prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him. But there
were many other revelation besides these
four which are mentioned in the Quran.
Five numbers of